it is time now for CBS morning's deals
where we show you products that might
make your day a little better all an
exclusive low low prices to start
shopping now scan the QR code that you
see on the screen or visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle hostgail bass joins us now
good morning Joe what's up good morning
Vlad to Dad it's so good to be here this
is something you really want to invest
in because all right talking bread yeah
you can't afford to waste food no at
Tupperware is bread saver I got a baby
yeah yeah there will be bread that'll
sit there that if you don't use this it
might get a little moldy this is
designed to take away the condensation
minimize condensation and add
ventilation you can see there are holes
right there you can see in the video
there are holes right there that let the
air just kind of surround the bread so
it lasts longer how long can you keep
breading you can keep bread as long as
you it lasts in your house really that's
that that's the thing because if you've
got a lot of kids and and they're like
getting sandwiches and making stuff on
their own you know you put the bread in
there they take it in and they take it
out if you're not on a you don't want to
eat a lot of bread but you got this big
Loaf and it's just for you like me this
is perfect because it keeps the bread
longer it lasts longer for me because
it's just me eating the bread so this is
a way where you can you can't afford to
waste your bread no so uh what is this
gonna run me yeah you're going to want
to go to cbsdeals.com and get this right
now very popular because it's 20.99 wow
for 30 off this is a big seller people
like it I would imagine so all right
let's talk about water now I need a
little bread need a little water yeah
especially in Arizona where I live you
know this Earth Day is coming up this
weekend and this is a great way to
purify your water and what's really cool
is that this does not use plastic beads
in the filter like other filters this
uses coconut shells that's interesting
yeah this is the hydros water pitcher
and we have it in the 40 ounce and the
60 ounce what's really great is that
this filter is interchangeable with all
with both of these these can switch as
well yes and one of the things that's
annoying I think for a lot of people
with the other type types of filters is
you get that charcoal stain in your
carafe after a little bit not this one
this one is beautifully designed I
really love the glass that it's made
with and this is sustainable and also
what I like about it is that it takes
six about a minute to fill it up you
just put your water at a third of the
rate you fill it up and boom there you
go and you can put it in the
refrigerator this fits in on the door on
the fridge so it fits every anywhere you
want it and here have a sample let me
try it you have it it's acceptable to
drink this one has my lipstick
no tannins
tastes very good how much is it going to
cost we have it for 25 off so we start
at 26.25 for this this is something you
definitely want to have I mean I'm in
all right uh let's talk about something
that can help people from slipping and
falling in the bathroom yeah this is the
Kahuna grip and I love that they call it
Kahuna grip because it's inspired by
Surfers they're on the surfboard they
don't want to slip and fall this is
designed unlike the Bon Jovi album this
is this is designed to be not this is
designed to be not Slippery When Wet so
it's a peel and stick you put it in the
shower it has multiple varieties and so
when you have somebody visiting who's a
little older or just not stable on their
feet this is something where you can
think about the safety when you're
stepping and this happens to me my
boyfriend's got old tiles in the shower
every day I'm thinking you're slipping
inside this is going to be the day is
this going to be the day where I was
like coming in with a brace on my foot
everybody help me I follow it I can't
get up we don't want that yeah yeah we
have a great value on this we have this
for 28 off so it starts at
15.99 and I love that it's peel and
stick and like I love the bamboo style
too I love it all right uh last but not
least this is a Magic Carpet fly oh this
this is this is totally fly and I love
this for I love this for parents because
this is eco-friendly and washable so if
babies take it into that baby wakes up
baby spills Cheerios or whatever it is
on the floor milk or what if you spill
red wine on the white shag this is
washable so you have that party and
there's always somebody who's going to
Spill the Wine on the expensive carpet
this is what you want how much uh this
starts at 54.99 and look we have a
variety of colors of matches I like it
Gail bass always great to have you thank
you very much of course we partner with
all these companies to get these deals
to buy anything that you saw today scan
that QR code on your screen or head over
to cbsdeals.com to start shopping now